in wenigen Tagen ist es soweit der
schlimmste jahrestag des Jahres ein Jahr
Krieg in der Ukraine von Putin wissen
sie ursprünglich geplant als ja
entspannter Kurztrip jetzt sitzt er
wahrscheinlich wütend im Kremmen und
fragt sich warum zieht sich das alles so
hin ja warum wohl warum wohl wegen der
Tapferkeit der Ukraine natürlich bei den
tobt einen brutaler abnutzungskrieg
Putins Kalkül der Westen soll die Geduld
verlieren und dafür gibt es leider
aktuell auch ein paar Indizien wie z.B
die sogenannte panzerallianz ja den
modernen Leo A6 liefern nur Portugal und
wir dabei hat der Kanzler doch neulich
bei mir EU-Gipfel ja wirklich alles
gegeben um unsere Partner zu motivieren
in seiner bekannt dynamischen Art
natürlich
habe ich noch mal die Gelegenheit
genutzt viele
darum zu bitten dass sie aktiv
unterstützen meine Eindruck ist das
läuft
ja also ich sag mal so wenn die Panzer
so schnell kommen wie Scholz was erklärt
dann steht Putin bald vor Dortmund er
kommt immerhin hält Deutschland seine
lieferversprechen im Gegensatz zu
anderen von wegen Bremser Scholz ruft
mir nach aber hinter ihm ist gar keiner
wie könnte dieser Krieg enden die Frage
aller Fragen in einer neuen
Allensbach-Umfrage finden Achtung
41% der ostdeutschen dass die Ukraine
ihren Widerstand einstellen sollte
darunter vermutlich einige die sonst bei
Demos gerne wieder stand rufen aber
natürlich nur gegens impfen nicht gegen
Putin das ist ja klar und dann auch noch
das hier manche von euch sind vermutlich
überrascht mich hier mit Sarah
Wagenknecht Schulter an Schulter zu
sehen
aber es gibt ein sehr ernsten Grund
dafür ja dann sagt das doch mal euren
Gesichtern
man sieht das Bild und denkt hoffentlich
nehmen die beiden kein Album zusammen
auf nee stattdessen haben sie
unterstützt von diversen Promis ein
Manifest für den Frieden an Vladimir
Putin geschickt ach sorry an Olaf Scholz
mein Fehler aber Putin hat sich trotzdem
drüber gefreut glaube ich die Ukraine
garantiert nicht so und das ist kein
Wunder ich meine stell dir mal vor du
wirst von Russland überfallen und dann
liest du einen Brief in dem deutsche
Oberlehrerin die erklären wie ein
Kompromiss funktioniert Leute es muss
doch ein Kompromiss geben zwischen Putin
kriegt die ganze Ukraine und Putin gar
nichts irgendwas muss er doch kriegen
für seine Mühe erstmal den bisherigen
Landraub einfrieren einfrieren heißt
nicht dass die Ukraine akzeptiert dass
diese Gebiete weg sind sondern dass man
eben mit nicht mil historischen Mitteln
am Ende entscheidet am besten die
Menschen selber fragt zu welchem Land
sie gehören wollen ja weiß ich jetzt gar
nicht ob man die noch fragen muss wo die
hingehören weil die heißen ja Ukraine
daran erkennt man es Referenten in der
Ostukraine sind eine Farce wenn man den
Wahlzettel in aller Regel neben einer
entsicherten Kalaschnikow ausfüllt das
weiß die Wagenknecht ganz genau warum
geht die immer noch als Expertin und
sitzt in 1000 Talkshows die hat vier
Tage nur vier Tage vor Putins Angriff
war eine will gesessen und gefragt warum
bitte sollte der in die Ukraine ein
marschieren was ja teilweise
herbeifantasiert wird wir können
heilfroh sein dass der Putin nicht so
ist wie er dargestellt wird nämlich
einen durchgeknallter russischer
Nationalist der sich daran berauscht
Grenzen zu verschieben
das stimmt da haben wir den Putin ja
alle völlig falsch eingesetzt für
Idioten für Sarah ist er bis heute der
knuffige Kumpel Typ den der Westen in
die Ecke drängt alles nur Notwehr ein
Schrei nach Liebe natürlich von der
Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt aber wie kann
man wenn man es gelesen hat dass man die
fest unterschreiben alte Faustregel wenn
nicht mal Richard David Precht und Till
Schweiger mitmachen stimmt was nicht
so merke ich es mir die Unterzeichner
fordern das Ende der Waffenlieferung
gleichzeitig heißt es Zitat die von
Russland brutal überfallende ukrainische
Bevölkerung braucht unsere Solidarität
wie schön ja aber wenn die Ukraine nur
noch Solidarität kriegt und keine Waffen
wird sie überrollt was ist das denn für
eine Solidarität klar man könnte weiß
ich nicht 5000 Ohrstöpsel schicken gegen
den russischen Raketen lernen ähm Ali
schwarzer bietet 30% Rabatt auf alle
neuen Emma Abos in der Ukraine plus ein
Autogramm von Jutta Speidel die auch
unterschrieben hat und der Unterzeichner
Reinhard Mey singt live in Kiew über dem
Don Bass darf die Freiheit nicht
grenzenlos sein aber das das
solidarischste die Friedenskämpfer
klatschen jeden Abend vom Balkon für die
Ukraine Gänsehaut
also bestimmt
glaube ich haben da auch Leute
unterschrieben die ist gut nein franz
Alt margottesmann
heißt zufällig genau wie jemand der
früher mal für die heute schon
gearbeitet hat Sachen gibt
naja nicht zu vergessen nicht zu
vergessen Wolfgang Grupp Wolfgang grub
legendärer Trigema Chef und selfmade
Millionär was sagen da eigentlich jetzt
die Mitarbeiter high Fans hiermit möchte
ich mich als Trigema Affe ausdrücklich
von meinem chefdistanzieren der Gruppe
ist jetzt leider offiziell wahnsinnig
geworden unschuldige Affen verkleiden
reicht ihm wohl nicht mehr kurz gesagt
ich kündige guten Abend
ein Affe mit Rückgrat meine Damen und
Herren der kann hier morgen als
Außenreporter anfangen
weite Teile des offenen Briefes sind
leider identisch mit Putins Propaganda
narrativ
da ist es zum Beispiel die Ukraine die
Ukraine könne doch gegen eine Atom macht
ähnlich gewinnen also lieber gleich
aufgeben ne stimmt kann man nicht
gewinnen das Gute außer jetzt damals in
Vietnam ne ne gute in Afghanistan aber
sonst völlig richtig völlig richtig
überaller und überfallende werden
aufgefordert endlich zu verhandeln
leider klingen putinsideen für den
Frieden aber so vor Ukraine
Ukraine
ja also ich kann mich irren aber wer vom
liquidieren träumt ist oft kein guter
Verhandlungspartner
ja Waffen im Kriegsgebiete liefern ist
furchtbar aber was wäre denn die
Alternative ein Europa in dem nur noch
das rechtes brutalsten gilt gut was
leider stimmt die Zeiten werden
insgesamt immer unsicherer Stichwort
spionageballons über Nordamerika der
Konflikt USA China kommt ja noch dazu
und wer hätte das gedacht die neueste
Bedrohung kommt direkt aus dem 18
Jahrhundert der Ballon
erfunden 1783 insgesamt vier unbekannte
Flugobjekte wurden schon abgeschossen
von den Amerikanern aber steckt da
wirklich immer China dahinter es ist ein
Spionage Thriller
absolut ja da muss man sich auch mal an
die eigene Spionage fassen meine Damen
und Herren statt immer nur auf China und
seine Balance zu schimpfen eventuell
heißt es jetzt haben die Amis mit den
letzten Abschüssen doch etwas
überreagiert andererseits wer weiß
vielleicht ist die Wahrheit in Wahrheit
ja noch viel schrecklicher
UFOs über Amerika Außerirdische
mysteriösen mögliche Invasion von Aliens
aus kundschaften der Außerirdischen das
sind das für Objekte wer steckt dahin
Invasion können wir glaube ich überhaupt
nicht gebrauchen was ist denn da nur los
am Himmel
[Musik]
ja ganz recht die verdammten Aliens
seriöse deutsche Leitmedien am tagelang
spekuliert über Außerirdische Invasionen
wir lachen aber ist Deutschland darauf
eigentlich vorbereitet im Ernstfall
tatsächlich gibt es im niederrheinischen
Kalkar Uedem das sogenannte Lagezentrum
für Sicherheit im deutschen Luftraum wo
gerade Valerie Niehaus Wachdienst hat
von hier aus wie läuft's heute schon
grüne Männchen gesichtet ja sehr witzig
sie sind doch der erste der rumholt wenn
die Außerirdischen kommen und anfangen
wahllos deutsche für rektale Experimente
zu entführen
die Alien Theorie ist eben nicht völlig
aus der Luft gegriffen oder haben sie in
meinem amerikanischen Kollegen neulich
nicht zugehört bislang ist unklar um
welche Objekte es sich handelt
Kommandeur des us-nordkommandos schließt
auch eine Zusammenhang mit
Außerirdischen nicht aus
erschließt es nicht aus heißt die
Invasion hat schon begonnen also wir
hier im Lagezentrum gehen jedenfalls
davon aus dass die Aliens längst unter
uns leben Jahre lang haben wir uns
lustig gemacht zum Beispiel über
Reptiloiden aber was wenn es sie
wirklich gibt und sie sich einfach nur
perfekt tarnen
um Gottes Willen um Gottes Willen also
Frauen nie aus ich Grusel mich ja auch
gerne aber
müsst wenn ich eher über den eventuell
eskalierenden Konflikt zwischen den USA
und China sprechen die Chinesen
chinesische Flugobjekte über Deutschland
was sollen die denn bitte bei uns
ausspionieren den Bauplan für den
Thermomix nein nein die Spur führt uns
allen ja völliger Bullshit fragen Sie
mal einen richtigen Astronauten erklärt
ihm wie absurd das ist
nebenan ist während Aliens dann kann man
zeigen dass sie einige tausend Jahren
bräuchten und vom nächsten Stern zu uns
zu kommen
tausende von Jahren klingt lang aber
verglichen mit einem durchschnittlichen
deutschen ICE
guck mal so bei den Aliens ist das Wort
Restaurant garantiert geöffnet die
Sprecherin des Weißen Hauses hat gerade
noch mal wörtlich gesagt es gibt keinen
Hinweis auf Außerirdische Aktivitäten
oder Aliens bei den Abschüssen ja
natürlich das muss sie ja sagen als
Alien und sie schlafen das
oh Alarm ein unidentifiziertes
Flugobjekt über den Sauerland das dürfte
eigentlich nicht sein heute wird fast an
allen Flughäfen gestreckt was ist das
ich brauche ein Bild
ja das sieht doch aus wie ein kleines
Privatflugzeug ich brauche vergrößert
sofort
ist das etwa Friedrich Merz aber
vielleicht wollen die Aliens ja auch nur
dass ich denke das wäre Friedrich Merz
Kampfjet Staffel sofort starten ich
wiederhole Kampfjets starten toi toi toi
Valerie vielen Dank
sie sind unter uns so liebe Zuschauer
vielen Dank ganz fette Überraschung die
CDU kann plötzlich Großstadt wow holt in
Berlin sensationelle
28,2%. jetzt die schlechte Nachricht die
Stadt ist schon wieder geteilt
allerdings verläuft die Grenze nicht
mehr zwischen Ost und West wie früher
sondern zwischen Innenstadt und
außenbezogen Sie müssen sich das so
vorstellen man ist außen schwarz und in
grün so können wir es erklären also im
Grunde
im Grunde ein Spiegelbild unserer
gespaltenen Gesellschaft also Latte
Macchiato gegen Berliner Weiße jungen
gegen alt Hipster gegen künstliche Hüfte
oder so ähnlich
immerhin haben sie die Wahl diesmal
fehlerfrei organisiert oder bei der
wiederholten Bar zum Abgeordnetenhaus in
Berlin gab es dann in der Norden Fehler
im Bezirk Lichtenberg sind nachträglich
466 aufgetaucht sie waren in der
Poststelle des Bezirks liegengeblieben
ja natürlich gut das ist der Vorteil
wenn du Berlin bist es erwartet eh
keiner mehr was von dir ne hier das
Zweitstimmenergebnis nach Wahlkreisen
sie sehen da ist nichts mehr rot und
ganz viel schwarz
sieht aus wie ein altes Röntgenbild von
Helmut Schmidt ein
ein totales Debakel für die SPD jetzt
ist Demut gefordert von den Sohn oder
wenigstens irgendwas was so klingt die
Berliner und Berliner haben mir gesagt
wir wollen was anders haben das ist
nicht einfach so weitergehen kann so wie
es ist kann es eben nicht bleiben
es braucht Veränderung alle wollen dass
ich Dinge verändern wir müssen Dinge
auch verändern weitergehen wie bisher
kann es nicht dafür braucht es die SPD
nee eigentlich nicht
nichts darf so bleiben wie es ist
deswegen bleibt sehr wahrscheinlich die
komplette Regierung in Berlin so wie sie
ist 74 Prozent der Berliner sind mit
Rot-Rot-Grün und zufriedenen Umfragen
alle drei Parteien haben verloren Frau
Giffey und die grüne Spitzenkandidatin
haben sogar ihre Direktmandate verloren
was bleibt da noch so ihr Lieben das
wichtigste die Stimmung ist schon mal
gut war
Hauptsache was
wie soll neu anfangen gehen mit einer
SPD die seit 21 Jahren Berlin regiert
natürlich assoziieren die Bürger fast
alles was schief läuft in der Stadt
hauptsächlich mit den socen und dann
verliert man eben sogar gegen einen
Unternehmensberater aus Spandau den
neuen cdu-shootingstar neben Friedrich
Merz an seiner Seite der eigentliche
Wahlsieger in Berlin CDU Spitzenkandidat
wie hieß er noch gleich Pandoria
ich habe mich schon gewundert dass Mario
Basler plötzlich so sympathisch
rüberkommt
kein Wegner ja kein Wegner möchte
Regierender Bürgermeister werden aber
mit wem mit wem an seiner Seite meine
Theorie wenn Sie das interessiert SPD
und Grüne führen jetzt nur
scheingespräche mit dem armen Mann die
spielen mit seinem Gefühl hier Foto love
story
[Musik]
der coole Gewinner Typ kai hat bei der
Wahl voll abgeräumt und heute gleich
zwei heiße Dates klar gemacht er träumt
schon vom wilden rum koalieren mit
Franzi oder Betty die kommen dann auch
haben aber einfach nur Weib Kai geht
trotzdem aufs Ganze ich kann mir beim
Verkehr wirklich alles vorstellen sagte
die beiden gehen direkt wegen Sexismus
und so mega Abfahrt für Kai dabei meint
er doch die autofreie Friedrichstraße
und dann fahren Franzi und Betty mit dem
Leder Klaus von den Linken in den
KitKatClub Ende
ja sie spielen in seinen Gefühlen heute
erste Verhandlung wird ewig tschüss ey
ernst gemeinter Vorschlag für einen
Neuanfang in Berlin wäre doch
Schwarz-Grün meine Alternative hatten
sie noch nie also quasi aus Latte
Macchiato und Berliner Weise ein
innovativen Cocktail mixen ja klingt
ekelhaft aber warum nicht
werden mal was Neues zumal der Union ja
ihr natürlicher Partner fehlt wissen Sie
die FDP einmal mehr gescheitert an der
5% Hürde was für ein anti-lauf seid ihr
Liberalen im Bund regieren schrumpfen
sie in den Ländern dramatisch sie
schrumpfen das ist der Hammer
was und das ist so bitte meine fünfte
Landtagswahl in Serie vergeigt und dann
auch noch die ultimative Demütigung
gehorcheltes Mitgefühl ich habe gestern
die Daumen gedrückt hätte sehr gehofft
dass die FDP reinkommt ich hätte mir
natürlich gewünscht dass die FDP den
Einzug ins Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus
schafft es ist leider nicht gelungen oh
ja natürlich Mitleid von Saskia Essen
tiefer kannst du nicht sinken man
spricht schon vom Leiden Christi und das
bedeutet natürlich bald noch mehr Ärger
in der Ampel ganz ganz toll fünf
Landtags bleiben in Folge tatsächlich
hatte Lindner wir haben es extra für sie
noch mal nachgeguckt tatsächlich hat der
Lindner zuletzt nur eine einzige Wahl
und zwar die zum Oldenburger Grünkohl
König ja und ich will diesen Grünkohl
erfolgt wirklich nicht kleinreden Gott
bewahre aber selbst der Titel ist
vielleicht nicht so geil wie er klingt
behauptet zumindest Christian Ehring
norddeutscher investigativreporter bei
unserem Partnersender NDR moin moin ja
Kurzzeit ist claimer ich bin eigentlich
im Rheinland geboren aber durch die
vielen Jahre beim NDR inzwischen
ehrenfischkopf besser habe ich zum
Beispiel rund um die Uhr
gummistiefeltrage
auch nachts aber das nur am Rande unser
Thema war ja Grünkohl bzw der bei uns im
Norden seit Jahren gefürchtete Fluch des
Grünkohlkönig
der was
ich schon sagte der Fluch des Grünkohl
König
in Oldenburg steht für Skandale und
Lügen erstmals wurde beim deftig
Oldenburger Grünkohl wie wir sagen auch
eine vegane Wurst gereicht
dabei macht ja die klassische
pinkelwurst im Grunde eine Art
explodierter schweinearsch im eigenen
Darm
die ganze Sache erst essbar und damit
sind wir auch schon bei den
Halbwahrheiten ich habe vor allen Dingen
eine Verbindung zum Grünkohl weil ich
muss mir hier heute nicht verbiegen
Grünkohl Essig von Kindesbeinen an
ohnehin immer schon gerne
natürlich ganz genau der sprechende
Maßanzug liebt Grünkohl wer soll das
denn glauben jetzt mal ernsthaft jemand
der sogar wenn er in Mali aus dem
Flieger steigt aussieht wie aus dem die
seiner Eigenfeld ja oder als wäre er
beim Casting
für fucking Top Gun
der ist doch im Leben keinen Grünkohl
glaub doch keine Oldenburger Sau aber
selbst wenn wieso ist das denn jetzt der
Fluch des Grünkohl Königs ja doch
perfekt
gucken würden oder wenigstens extra 3
dann wissen sie dass mit diesem
Königstitel Lindner Karriere so gut wie
beendet ist schauen Sie einfach mal
seine Vorgänger
selbst erklären Sigmar Gabriel
arbeitet heute als Callboy für Katar
Christian Wolf keine Ahnung wer das war
Frank Walter Steinmeier auch arbeitslos
weitesten Sinne Gutenberg
dr no Annette Schavan auch eine Doktor
know und nicht zu vergessen und jetzt
bin ich hier in Oldenburg Grünkohlkönig
und das freut mich und das ist der
Höhepunkt meiner politischen Karriere
und das aller traurigste ist damit hatte
der Peter sogar recht
ich merke schon sie sind immer nicht so
richtig überzeugt vom Flug dann zeige
ich Ihnen jetzt mal von wem Lindner den
verfluchten Grünkohl Thron übernimmt
[Musik]
keine weiteren Fragen Christian Ehring
meine Damen und Herren
ich glaube eh nicht dass das hier gerade
noch jemand sieht Wetten Liebe heute
show Fans wenn ihr das hier noch seht
schreibt in die Kommentare Gernot
hassknechts schauspielerische Darbietung
hat mich zu Tränen gerührt und abonniert
gerne den Kanal danke
und die endcard macht ihr jetzt hinter
jedes Video klar auch wenn ich nicht
darin vorkomme